Vou te ensinar sobre uma bola girando — só que não é uma bola e não está girando. Hoje, no Qiskit na
sala de aula, vamos falar sobre essa propriedade quântica chamada spin, analisando o experimento que encontrou as primeiras evidências dela.
Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na sala de aula. Nesta série, usamos o Qiskit para explorar alguns conceitos fundamentais comumente
abordados em cursos relacionados à computação quântica. Cada vídeo também é acompanhado de um módulo interativo
com o link na descrição abaixo, então não deixa de conferir. Hoje estamos falando sobre o experimento de Stern-Gerlach de 1922.
É um dos mais famosos da história da teoria quântica, porque demonstra de forma tão clara como o spin quântico
funciona. Mas não era isso que Stern ou Gerlach pretendiam mostrar. O experimento foi concebido para testar um novo modelo quântico
do átomo chamado modelo de Bohr, batizado em homenagem a Niels Bohr, que o propôs em 1913. No modelo, os elétrons orbitavam
o núcleo em orbitais discretos e podiam fazer transições entre esses orbitais absorvendo ou emitindo
fótons. Cada orbital tinha um momento angular quantizado que era um múltiplo inteiro de uma pequena constante fundamental
chamada ħ. Na década de 1910 e no início dos anos 20, a mecânica quântica era completamente nova — tão nova
que nem se chamava mecânica quântica ainda. Por isso, nem todos estavam convencidos do modelo de Bohr. Um físico
chamado Otto Stern odiava esse modelo. Ele o chamou de absurdo e chegou a ameaçar abandonar a física se Bohr fosse
provado certo. Stern estava tão determinado a provar que o modelo estava errado que criou uma forma engenhosa de testá-lo e
recrutou Walther Gerlach para ajudá-lo a projetar e realizar o experimento. Só que ele não provou que Bohr estava errado — acabou
provando que ele mesmo estava errado. O experimento deles foi tão simples e os resultados tão contundentes que praticamente encerrou o
debate: a mecânica quântica governa a escala atômica. Eles não perceberam na época,
mas o experimento de Stern e Gerlach também encontrou evidências conclusivas do spin intrínseco do elétron — uma
nova propriedade fundamental da natureza, essencial para explicar o magnetismo, a supercondutividade e grande parte da
química. Hoje vou te mostrar como o experimento de Stern-Gerlach funciona, o que esperaríamos ver classicamente,
e o que Stern e Gerlach de fato encontraram. Depois vou te mostrar como você pode rodar seu próprio experimento no estilo Stern-Gerlach
com o Qiskit e um computador quântico da IBM. A ideia básica do experimento de Stern-Gerlach
era encontrar uma forma de determinar se o momento angular de um elétron em um átomo era quantizado, como
Bohr previa, ou não, como Stern esperava. Eles usaram o fato de que o momento angular do elétron também criaria
um pequeno campo magnético ao redor de cada átomo. Então você pode pensar neles como pequenos ímãs de barra.
O experimento era assim: havia um forno cheio de átomos de prata
e um campo magnético com os polos norte e sul
aqui. O campo era mais forte perto do topo e mais fraco perto do fundo, produzindo um gradiente apontando para cima.
Por fim, havia uma tela. No experimento, o forno aquecia os átomos de prata até evaporarem, e então
eles saíam do forno com a orientação do pequeno ímã de barra de cada átomo completamente aleatória. Em seguida, os átomos
passavam pelo campo magnético. Os átomos eram empurrados para cima ou para baixo com uma força que dependia da direção do
polo norte de cada átomo em relação a esse gradiente de campo. Depois, os átomos atingiam a tela. Stern e Gerlach podiam observar
onde os átomos acertavam a tela para aprender sobre o momento angular dos elétrons. Stern esperava que os átomos
no experimento se comportassem como eu estive descrevendo até agora: como pequenos ímãs de barra que obedecem às
regras da física clássica. Classicamente, esses pequenos ímãs atômicos poderiam estar orientados em qualquer direção aleatória, então, enquanto
viajavam pelo campo magnético, poderiam experimentar uma variedade de forças diferentes empurrando-os para cima ou para baixo, dependendo dessas orientações. Um ímã
apontando na mesma direção que o gradiente experimentaria uma força grande para cima; na direção oposta,
uma força grande para baixo. E se estivesse em algum ponto intermediário, seria uma força mais fraca. Se o átomo estivesse apontando
perpendicular ao gradiente, não experimentaria nenhuma força e continuaria reto. Por causa dessa
variedade de forças possíveis, os átomos deveriam atingir a tela em diferentes pontos verticais. O padrão que formariam
na tela seria algo assim. Mas não foi isso que Stern e
Gerlach viram. Em vez disso, eles viram dois grupos completamente separados de átomos na tela, sem nenhum átomo no
centro. Eles não tinham a teoria correta na época para explicar isso, mas sabemos agora que viram isso porque
todo elétron tem uma certa quantidade de momento angular intrínseco na forma de spin, que só pode assumir um
de dois valores. Na nossa figura do ímã de barra, isso significa que só há duas orientações permitidas para os ímãs atômicos. Chamamos
essas duas orientações de spin up e spin down. Um qubit em um computador quântico
se assemelha a esse tipo de sistema de spin, e alguns computadores quânticos realmente usam qubits feitos a partir dos estados de spin do elétron.
Então podemos realizar nosso próprio experimento de Stern-Gerlach com o Qiskit e os qubits de um computador quântico da IBM. Vamos
mapear o estado spin up do elétron para o estado zero do qubit e o estado spin down para o estado um
do qubit. Quando as partículas de prata saíam do forno, tinham momentos magnéticos orientados aleatoriamente. Podemos
modelar o experimento de Stern-Gerlach criando um circuit quântico simples com um único qubit começando no estado zero.
Isso é chamado de diagrama de circuit, onde o fio do topo é o qubit e as operações aplicadas ao qubit
aparecem como caixas no fio. As caixas RX e RZ são gates quânticos que
efetivamente rotacionam a orientação magnética do átomo. Podemos escolher valores aleatórios de Theta e F aqui para rotacionar o
qubit uma quantidade aleatória. Isso imita o forno, que lança os átomos com orientações de spin aleatórias. A caixa cinza é
nossa medição. Ela nos diz se o qubit está no estado zero ou um e envia essa medição para um bit clássico —
a linha dupla rotulada C. Esta parte é equivalente a medir se o átomo está em spin up ou spin down observando em
qual ponto ele acerta a tela. Podemos usar uma primitiva do Qiskit chamada sampler para rodar o experimento várias vezes, cada uma com
valores aleatórios diferentes para Theta e F. Após 100 amostras, obtemos um histograma de medições que se parece com este — em torno de
50% das vezes o qubit é medido como zero e 50% das vezes está no estado 1. Esse é o mesmo resultado que Stern
e Gerlach obtiveram: é sempre spin up ou spin down, nunca algo intermediário. Nesse ponto, você pode estar pensando: bem,
claro que obtivemos dois resultados discretos — realizamos o experimento em um computador quântico digital, que sempre retorna
zero ou um. E isso é verdade. Mas lembre-se de que o único motivo pelo qual os computadores quânticos retornam resultados binários — de fato,
o motivo pelo qual a computação quântica funciona — é exatamente essa quantização do spin que Stern e Gerlach descobriram primeiro.
Os qubits nos computadores quânticos da IBM não são baseados em spins, mas muitos outros computadores quânticos são. Por isso, realizar um
experimento de Stern-Gerlach em um computador quântico nos permite, de fato, redescobrir a quantização do spin.
Desde 1922, inúmeras extensões do experimento original de Stern-Gerlach foram realizadas. Essas extensões envolvem
enviar o mesmo feixe de átomos por múltiplos aparelhos de Stern-Gerlach para ver como os spins se comportam em diferentes
cenários. Aqui está um: vamos enviar os átomos por um aparelho para separar o feixe em dois, correspondendo a um
feixe de spin up e um feixe de spin down, e então enviar cada um desses feixes por seus próprios aparelhos separados.
Com o Qiskit, o circuit quântico correspondente a esse experimento é similar ao anterior, mas com duas
medições em vez de uma. Aqui substituímos as rotações aleatórias que imitavam o efeito do forno por um
gate chamado Hadamard, pois aplicar o Hadamard nos dá as mesmas probabilidades de medição que o forno
fornecia, mas é muito mais simples de usar. Então medimos uma vez e depois uma segunda vez, e o
histograma de medições resultante do experimento se parece com este, onde as strings de bits no eixo X correspondem aos
resultados das duas medições. Se o qubit foi medido como zero nas duas vezes, isso corresponde à string de bits 0 0; ou se
foi medido primeiro como zero e depois como um, isso corresponde a um zero e assim por diante. Parece que se foi medido como spin up no
primeiro experimento, será spin up no segundo. O mesmo vale para os átomos de spin down. Isso significa que no primeiro experimento
tínhamos igual probabilidade de medir para cima ou para baixo, mas no segundo experimento o resultado já estava determinado. Então as
duas telas ao final de cada um dos segundos aparelhos de Stern-Gerlach teriam cada uma apenas um ponto — uma tela teria
todos os átomos de spin up e a outra teria todos os átomos de spin down. Para nosso próximo experimento, vamos
começar com um feixe de átomos puramente de spin up. Com um experimento físico real de Stern-Gerlach, você poderia fazer isso enviando
os átomos por um aparelho de Stern-Gerlach e bloqueando o feixe desviado para baixo, para que todos os átomos desviados para cima sejam
spin up. Agora vamos enviar esse feixe por outro aparelho de Stern-Gerlach, mas desta vez vamos girar os ímãs 90°, para que
o gradiente de campo desvie os átomos que estão se movendo desta forma para a esquerda ou para a direita. Veríamos
um ponto ou dois, ou algo completamente diferente? Para esse experimento,
vamos rodar o circuit a seguir no Qiskit. Vamos começar no estado zero, já que nosso feixe de átomos neste experimento são todos
spin up. Então esse gate Hadamard troca as coordenadas x e z, tendo o efeito de rotacionar o
aparelho de Stern-Gerlach. Agora estamos medindo a projeção do spin para a esquerda ou para a direita, em vez de para cima ou para baixo. Aqui obtemos
o histograma de medições que se parece com este. Podemos ver que o spin ao longo de X também só pode assumir dois valores,
que podemos chamar de spin left e spin right. Então esse experimento mostra que, se você mede a projeção X de um spin
que foi previamente medido como spin up ao longo de Z, ele terá spin left ou spin right com igual probabilidade. Vamos contrastar
isso uma última vez com a expectativa clássica, só para destacar bem a diferença. Classicamente, lembra que eu disse que se o pequeno
ímã atômico de barra estivesse apontando perpendicular ao gradiente de campo magnético do aparelho,
a força sobre esse átomo seria zero? Ele não deveria ser desviado para cima nem para baixo. Nesse caso, veríamos apenas um único ponto no
meio da tela. Em vez disso, vemos dois pontos. Então metade dos átomos tem spin left e metade tem spin right, mesmo
tendo sido medidos anteriormente como up. Então, de uma perspectiva da mecânica quântica, embora possa ser tentador
equiparar spin up a um vetor apontando para cima e spin down a um apontando para baixo, não é tão simples assim, como podemos ver
a partir do último experimento. Para realmente entender o que está acontecendo aqui, precisaremos nos aprofundar nos tópicos de
superposição quântica e medição — o que será assunto para outro vídeo. Assim como ficamos com mais
perguntas sobre como exatamente a mecânica quântica funciona, o mesmo aconteceu com Stern e Gerlach. O experimento deles não explicou
tudo, mas foi muito longe para estabelecer a mecânica quântica como essencial para entender o mundo natural.
Foi um dos experimentos fundacionais mais importantes da mecânica quântica, que tanto provou a quantização
do momento quanto forneceu evidências de uma nova propriedade fundamental da natureza chamada spin. Para realmente entender e
assimilar as regras do mundo quântico, físicos como Stern e Gerlach tiveram que arregaçar as mangas para projetar
experimentos, fazer previsões e às vezes estar errados. Realmente não há substituto para tentar as coisas você mesmo.
Então, se tu queres tentar rodar alguns experimentos quânticos reais, acessa o módulo Stern-Gerlach
com o link na descrição. Obrigado por assistir e até a próxima!